bonsoir bonsoir d'entrée de jeu leur
rappelez-vous quand on parle de
consommation responsable on vient
d'effleurer le concept mais de quoi on
parle au Québec mais on parle vraiment
de tout ce qui est vraiment le poste
achat le nom d'achat et l'achat donc
c'est vraiment le cycle de vie de la
consommation c'est un comportement qui
est énorme personne ne peut être
complètement responsable donc c'est
vraiment des pratiques qui sont
extrêmement grandes donc c'est sûr que
c'est très difficile d'évaluer l'ampleur
de la consommation responsable mais ça
fait quand même 13 ans qu'on regarde
comment évolue la consommation
responsable au Québec donc ça donne une
image quand même sociologique
intéressante et baromètre 13e édition
particulièrement intéressante dans le
contexte d'inflation et on sent que ça
teinte votre rapport votre baromètre
2022 tout au long de quelle manière ça
bouscule les habitudes des Québécois
complètement on est dans un
environnement qui a jamais été aussi
turbulent en deux ans de pandémie
l'inflation on avait vécu des
reconfigurations de pratique de
consommation les vraiment on avait vu
les comportements changer des habitudes
qui avaient fortement évolué et là la
pandémie est en train de tout dire
l'inflation en train de tout
rechambouler complètement donc là on va
concrètement qu'on a énormément de
pratiques de consommation responsables
qui diminue et ce qui est en train de
changer mais forcément c'est la sobriété
modération de la consommation et on a
des consommateurs qui vont vers
l'optimisation de la consommation il
cherche à mieux consommer en optimisant
donc réduction et on s'en va vers des
consommations plus alternatives
consommation de seconde main tout ce qui
est la consommation collaborative et on
voit que le facteur prix devient
fondamental dans les choix des
consommateurs
que justement c'est un c'est central
dans la décision le prix c'est
l'impression qu'on en a c'est à dire que
si l'inflation jusqu'à un certain point
incite à des comportements
éco-responsables c'est par nécessité
monsieur Durif donc la sous-cestion
c'est est-ce que ce sera durable quand
la hausse des prix sera moins vite
est-ce qu'on va revenir avec des
habitudes éco-responsables ou pas c'est
toujours la question qu'on se pose parce
que reprendre une habitude c'est
extrêmement complexe déjà la développer
généralement il faut au moins 6 à 9 mois
à chaque fois c'est ce qu'on voit mais
là la crainte c'est de repère les bonnes
habitudes parce qu'on avait vu quand
même vu des Québécois qui avait atteint
des comportements de consommation resto
extrêmement intéressant notamment sur
l'achat local sur les achats de bien
éco-responsables donc là c'est assez
dangereux parce que là ce qu'on voit
c'est concrètement et c'est tout à fait
normal l'inflation n'a jamais été aussi
fort depuis plus d'une trentaine
d'années on va concrètement qu'on s'en
va vers des produits arabés vers des
marques de distributeur on voit
véritablement qu'on choisit de plus en
plus on compare les prix donc forcément
ça se au détriment de bien
écoresponsable par contre ce qui est
intéressant c'est la modération de la
consommation donc on voit quand même que
ça reste dans une partie de
conscientisation sociale ça ça baisse
pas de plus en plus de consommateurs
disent je modère à cause de la
conscience sociale mais c'est quand même
essentiellement une question de
d'augmentation des prix donc c'est quand
même fortement subi dans les variations
les plus importantes vous avez analysées
évidemment plusieurs types de
comportements plusieurs types de
consommation l'achat local en
particulier est une des catégories où on
voit que ça ça diminue le plus on se
tourne de moins en moins vers les
commerces de proximité les commerces
locaux or vous le dites on est conscient
il y a eu tellement d'appels à la
consommation locale le panier bleu on
est encore conscient de leur présence
est-ce qu'on va revenir vers ces
commerces de proximité on voit c'est
très important dans les valeurs des
Québécois pour eux la motivation
principale c'est l'engagement économique
donc depuis le début de la pandémie ça
n'a jamais cessé la problématique c'est
qu'on voit que depuis un an et demi ça
ne cesse finalement le passage à
l'action parce que là il faut arriver
finalement à faire en sorte que l'offre
soit accessible à l'ensemble des
consommateurs là c'est la problématique
on voit que le prix redevient un
obstacle extrêmement fort au niveau de
la chaleur locale ça a toujours été le
frein majeur mais là il devient encore
plus fondamental donc c'est là qu'il va
avoir le défi finalement des autorités
publiques il y a énormément de
sensibilisation en ce moment avec la
nouvelle certification donc je pense que
les efforts vont certainement porter
fruits pour continuer à faire que
l'engagement économique va transcender
la question peut-être du prix on
l'espère me la pression financière reste
très très vive le dit à une donnée très
intéressante dans votre rapport on dit
les trois quarts des Québécois se
perçoivent déjà comme consommateur
éco-responsable le corps dise j'en fais
assez pour réduire mon impact
environnemental ça nous dit quoi ces
données-là mais ça c'est toujours assez
inquiétant parce que on a quand même une
base de consommateur qui ont toujours
l'impression qu'ils sont relativement
responsables on se présente on a
toujours l'impression qu'on est un peu
mieux que ce on est dans la réalité ce
qui est inquiétant c'est qu'on a quand
même une parasser importante des
consommateurs qui ne veulent pas faire
plus de citoyens qui sont peut-être un
peu fatigués c'est sûr qu'on nous
demande beaucoup de choses il y a
beaucoup de campagne d'éducation de
sensibilisation on nous demande de
passer fortement à l'action il y a
beaucoup de citoyens qui ont
l'impression que déjà ils en font
énormément et là dans un contexte et de
pandémie et d'inflation c'est peut-être
un trop plein pour beaucoup de citoyens
donc c'est toujours la difficulté pour
pour les autorités d'arriver à faire en
sorte que le passage à l'action se fasse
dans la facilité parce que c'est
vraiment ça la difficulté pour beaucoup
de citoyens aujourd'hui et bon la
pression de l'inflation et des prix on
la comprend bien je me suis durée
comment on explique que un recul des
habitudes de recyclage ça a toujours été
le comportement le plus élevé au Québec
là on a une légère baisse de la pratique
globale de ceux qui sont les adeptes les
plus forts donc de ceux qui ont
l'intensité la plus élevée
on voit ça un peu aussi dans le
comportement de protection de
l'environnement dans donc par contre ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'on voit que
le compostage est en légère hausse donc
je pense qu'il y a un petit peu des
difficultés peut-être aussi que certains
citoyens ont l'impression que ils ont
atteint tout le monde recycle donc des
fois je pense être un comportement qui a
quand même une belle perception donc un
moment donné c'est aussi c'est des
tendances à l'intérieur de la société
mais je pense aussi Quebec fait un très
fort travail de d'éducation de
sensibilisation là-dessus on s'arrête
là-dessus merci beaucoup monsieur dufe
d'avoir été là merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI